Manila the capital of the Philippines
with a population of 10 million the city
is overflowing with people and the dead
Manila's North cemetery is the city's
largest with 70 to 80 funerals a day and
more than 1 million buried here it's
filled beyond capacity spilling over
with corpses for most this would be a
chilling place to visit but to some
Filipinos this sea of tombs and bones is
the place they call home
an entire community built on top of the
dead ray meal and Rito has lived in the
city of death since 1988 hey did they
find it on a lot of people think it's
scary to live here inside the cemetery
he turned an aboveground tomb into a
two-story house few people would want to
do their laundry only feet away from a
corpse and a crypt or brush their teeth
on top of a gravestone there's even an
empty tomb inside Raimi's living room
this will be the grave for my family
whoever is first to go will be buried
here
ramie lives here by choice because this
is where he works his job is only a few
tombstones away and it's not for the
squeamish at least three times a day
Rainey must exhume the dead with space
and money scarce many poor families must
rent burial sites here in what are
called the apartments and like any
tenant the dead can be evicted if the
rent isn't paid after five years the
apartment is opened then it's Rama's job
to remove the body piece by piece
decomposed or not
it's a task that took some getting used
to when I first started here at the
cemetery the first time I handled bones
I couldn't eat for two weeks I couldn't
sleep
my stomach was upset I felt like
throwing up but three weeks into the job
I got used to it little by little and I
started eating again here death is
everywhere literally staring residents
in the face in this neighborhood
unclaimed bodies litter front yards
becoming children's playthings or
ballast for tin rooftops but ramie a
devout Catholic places the unclaimed
corpses in a mass grave so that their
souls may rest in peace those who don't
have money to ribéry the bones they're
stored here there are more than 2,000
bodies here in the Philippines caring
for graves isn't a matter of placing
flowers once a year and that's what
makes it possible for the cemeteries
residents to live here many people want
to have someone to tend their loved ones
crypts on a full-time basis Mario for
malleus an epitaph maker has called the
cemetery home for over 25 years
Mario's lease agreement is one few
Westerners would want to sign take care
of a crypt and its corpses and you can
move in with them for free and in turn
his family has a place to live people
ask me why tell them because rent is
free everything is from even with otter
it may be creepy but it's also quiet and
safe particularly when compared to the
slums of Manila where squalor and drugs
are part of daily life
brainy Landry dough does hope that
someday his son jr. will find a home far
from the tombs and coffins of the
cemetery but until then
Rama's family and others like Mario for
malice will continue to live in a place
many would find taboo doesn't even mean
this really isn't a place for the living
without poppy latinum was a place for
the dead but in the end it's our home